cory booker he is the mayor of newark
right now but he is the Democratic
nominee for Senator for New Jersey to
replace Frank Lautenberg who kicked the
bucket after he was like 177 years old
and he most likely will be the next
senator from New Jersey to come over on
the Mayflower fact right there from
Jimmy Dore that's right that was an old
that was a neat joke there you go that
was an old joke in an Asian so the thing
is with Cory Booker I did not know this
but apparently there are gay rumors
around him he's always been very proud
he's always been very Pro gay I actually
interviewed him once at at a gay event I
thought he was married and until I read
this story I thought he was married I
thought he was a great guy
I just gotta say he was a great guy we
actually talked about basketball mostly
but he did do that interview on your lap
right he was sitting on my lap naked
which is right but Eddy who is Christmas
he has addressed sort of gay rumors this
week and I think did it in a really
interesting way let's take a look and
people who think I'm gay some part of me
thinks it's wonderful because I want to
challenge people on their homophobia I
love seeing on Twitter when someone says
I'm gay and I say so what does it matter
if I'm if I am so be it
I hope you were not voting for me
because you are making the presumption
that I'm straight there's a little bit
of sort of antithetical sort of
backwards speak logic in there but I
kind of think it's great yes I think
it's great and you know what okay really
doesn't matter if he's gay or not he's
not married I think I read in our story
that he said he went and and seeked out
a pastor or something and the pastors
like he wanted some advice and he goes
get married and he's like wait a minute
that what I mean you don't have to be
married to be a mayor or a senator or
whatever sure maybe it looks kind of
weird because most men and at that age
and in that profession usually have a
family because they want to present the
family life or whatever but who cares
either way yeah I give a he's been
nothing then beyond Pro gay and this is
a guy who runs into burning houses to
save families and when the hurricane
happened he had people staying at his
house and he's like moving you know
light fixtures that have fallen this guy
he's a
pretty good guy so look obviously I'm
pro-gay shoot more than you're gonna
like it sexuality right should we just
regard it's relevant right I'm answering
question well you know as far as my
voting goes it's pretty irrelevant I
think but it is relevant in a sense like
like he's a politician he needs people
to vote for them like if Robertson
that's why Kevin Spacey still hasn't
come out right because it does affect
the way people vote for you it does
affect the ticket sales so if Robert
DeNiro came out as gay would probably
mess around with his box office even
though I don't think people hold it
against them but just there's a thing
you wanna be Wanna like someone in a
certain way yeah and that's what I'm you
know I mean the thought that he's gay it
bothers you more than that he's a
middle-aged man that's not married and
doesn't have a family no it doesn't
bother me what bothers me about cory
booker is that he's a tool of wall
street he's gay I mean III in fact I
think it's almost if he was gay would be
for me a positive because it would it
would mean that he has an a more open
mind about the way world works yeah so
that's for me but those people I don't
think would feel that way okay so if he
was a Republican and he had gone and and
had a platform that was anti-gay or he
was against marriage equality or any
that stuff we'd obviously all be against
that right I think I can speak for us
there but is there something even more
dangerous if he is gay and again I'm not
saying he is I'm not even putting the
rumor out that at all but let's just say
it was someone of his stature that was
gay
but still closeted and still Pro gay is
there even more danger in that in a
weird way do you think that that's
possible I'd like to ask the gay
community that you know does that bother
you that somebody that you think is
potentially gay that is Pro gay in his
you know public political standings and
and but he won't come out I mean does
that bug you to give him not outting
cory booker i think he's straight i met
him i believe i'm sorry you know i
it doesn't because it doesn't matter to
me if he's a good mayor if he's a good
senator then who cares I mean it's his
constituents in the end that are gonna
have to to vote and go we like this guy
he stood up for us he had people in his
house he runs into burning but you know
whatever it's like who cares about a
sexuality you know what I mean it's like
it can he run our government over the
gay stuff give me 30 seconds on the Wall
Street stuff because I basically like
him but he is pretty close to Wall
Street and and it's been a lot of
problems so let's so let's bang them up
a little bit legitimately do you think
that if well if you're like me and you
think the biggest part of our problem
right now in our economy is that the
wall street's control of it well then
you'll think that cory booker has
probably got the worst flaw you can have
it as a candidate so that's what I think
like Wall Street's them and invest their
money right that's every politician
there's almost everybody no you're right
that's I mean that that that's why
there's wolf pack and that's why there's
people trying to get money out of
politics you're exactly right he's no
he's not unique in his no you're right
yeah all right well whether you're gay
or not Booker let's let's ease up on the
Wall Street connection okay yeah hey
Dave that I don't care if he's gay as
long as he has the strong shoulders in
the bedroom eyes Ritchie the mitt he's
incredibly fit you'd like to wrestle
with him wouldn't you very handsome